spell chess
Okay so
I guess I should explain how this game
works
for those that maybe haven't seen it
before or didn't watch my previous video
about it but I think I'll start a game
and I'll explain it as we go and
basically this is chess with spells
and the Spells are jump and freeze
I've been playing a little bit of this
off stream too so I'm trying to learn
the Wizardry that goes into this game
um now I'm gonna play a Carol Khan C6
but I'm not gonna play D5 I'm gonna play
G6
let me update the stream title as well
chess
okay
and the instructions are here for anyone
that wants to maybe squint and read them
but uh
yeah basically it's normal chess but on
a given move you can opt to use one of
the Spells
which I don't really have any reason for
yet
so so far it's just normal chess
um
eventually
I'm gonna use one of my freezes
and the way the freeze works it frees a
three by three square or three by three
radius for a single move
so I'm thinking about like
taking the knights
although no I don't want to do that so
here my opponent is actually threatening
to use their jump spell to jump over the
pawn to take my queen
and I'm thinking I'm I can counter with
the freeze
yeah let's counter
with this
so I use my freeze and then I play F6
so now White's in a position where the
bishop Knight and pawn are frozen so
they can't move any of them any of these
things
for the next move
and I'm ready to capture the bishop
so this is one way to try and win
material
chest is hard enough
it's it's definitely adds a layer of
complication
be interesting to add duck chess on top
of spell chess
spell duchess
so my opponent counter row counter for
used
and now I can't take the bishop so yeah
unfortunately it kind of canceled out
there
let's attack this
but I think this is still working out
because okay we traded freezes
but now white has two Bishops both
attacked
I guess
Bishop takes G8 as possible
spell chess plus cow opening equals holy
cow
yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure how great
the cow opening would be in spell chess
but
yeah maybe it's playable
there are a good amount of like opening
traps that can emerge from this game
at um
maybe we'll see in future games
okay so I want to play this movie but
I'm realizing that then the point can
jump and just take the
the bishop
so that would just backfire and if I
play this move opponent can jump and
take my queen
H5 Maybe
I think white was threatening maybe to
take or to jump and then take the H7
Pawn
okay so another thing about this game
when you use a spell it takes I think
three moves for the spell to replenish
and we only get two jumps and four now
four freezes started with five freezes
for the whole game
all right let's play c c five loses a
pawn though
maybe I can play before
so counter-attack in the knights
I think out of all the spell chess games
I've played I haven't had a single game
where either player uses all their
freezes
ooh okay so now I can play Queen A5
because the way that the jump works you
can only jump over one Pawn The Rook can
jump over two pieces
um
so my queen is safe and I'm threatening
to jump over my Pawn to win the white
king I'm also threatening the Knight
foreign just Flags
that was anticlimactic
uh what to do I could do viewer
challenges
oh yeah okay
uh okay let's play Let's play this okay
I'm gonna go for oh wait I'm playing a
national master
oh I'm playing Aiden R chess what's up
even
okay
I have not played the title player in
this game yet
so this will be
perhaps more of a challenge
and we'll see how experienced Aiden is
with this game
Aiden says I'm bad at it LOL
well there's no one who's like wait a
minute am I about to lose
I could play King E2
I was gonna say there's no one with like
so much experience since vouchers
hey this is a problem
I mean I could counter freeze a bishop
I have a counter freeze the bishop
I'm not sure what's happening I think
I'm just gonna play King E2
and save my freeze
because if I make any other like normal
move
then black is gonna take and jump over
my pawn and take the king so
uh
unexpected Bond cloud
okay so at least I have five freezes I
mean
opponent one a piece so
and now what to do
maybe this move
I feel so weird to try and play the
opening with my king on E2
why not free is a
I could have but
I'm gonna try and make the argument that
the freeze is more valuable than a minor
piece
basically just hoarding my freezes for
later
uh maybe G3 we have a closed position
by Queen
D3 is interesting too
because there's some idea of jumping and
taking the pawn
not sure if Aiden is still listening
I'm not sure how stalemate Works in this
game
although I think yeah I think there
should be still made because once you
run out of friezas and spa or freezes
and jumps it's just normal chess
wow is this a threat
that might be
I'm Not Afraid though I'm gonna play
this
so Bishop A6 and if I take then Rook
jumps over
oh interesting
okay
maybe I should like protect my king a
little bit more
or maybe I play this
I really don't know like the long-term
positional strategy
but I'm setting up a trap and we'll see
if uh appointment Falls for it
the game can end in either capturing the
king or checkmates
I think it's a little bit different than
duck chess
but you can't willingly play an illegal
move in this game as far as I know
okay so Bishop A6 is played which is
interesting
now I think I'll
I'll use my jump
I could also use my freeze
oh I have choices
jumper freeze
I think chump
so the way the jump works you click the
thing then you click which thing you
want to jump over and then you jump
Okay so
my Rook activates
now black could take back but then I
take and
uh basically I won my piece back
but I gave up one jump
which I think is okay
so Knight F5
ah interesting
oh It's Tricky
I play G4
like
opponent's threatening to do this
I gotta move quicker too
I think I'll do this
I gotta move much quicker
okay so I could take and then maybe
freeze
or freeze and then take so let's freeze
all of these
and then take
so I want to win the knights
but this is dangerous because I'm out of
spells opponent has both of their spells
my jump will replenish shortly
oh interesting so it's a counter freeze
I have this move
oh
if I take then jump
I don't think I can afford to take
take their their
unless I can now let's play this
Safety First
I was trying to calculate take they jump
I jump
it's too confusing
I didn't have my freeze because it's uh
it's still replenishing
okay but now I can take this
this is looking good Rooks can be very
strong in this game I think
now take this
12 seconds left
um and now let's do this and this
okay if freeze activated
oh fancy
but I defend
oh
I have a cool idea
I'm not sure if it works though
there there
hmm
okay I'm gonna try my cool idea oh no my
queen
and then I take
or then I'm going to deliver a check
and then take and then freeze
oh maybe this doesn't work
oh they can only use one spell at once
so
no no I usually jump on the wrong thing
I meant to use a freeze
oh
I clicked the wrong thing ah good game
if I freeze and then take
maybe I should have just taken without
doing anything
I was scared that opponent would
oh but if they freeze back it's still
meat I think
no I was afraid of um was I afraid of
also thanks for the rain thundering
I should have just taken
I meant to use the freeze to be extra
safe but
um
what I should have done was frozen this
area
so if I did this and then this
and then black could use a freeze but
they don't really have anything to move
I guess I could do this
oh they could do this and oh no they
oh they can't move their Rook if they
freeze a rook
so what if they do this
and then this
yeah this game is so mind-bending
yeah I should have just taken without
using a spell
and then if takes then this is where I
can jump the g-pawn and take
goodbye to Aiden thanks for the game
this is the first game I've lost on
stream
and there's actually a really funny idea
like let's say
let's say the pawns on G4
and
for whatever reason I wanna
play Pawn F4
so I use my jumps file I play Pawn F4
this is a situation
where black can double capture
because when the Knight is captured it's
also on poisson
someone commented this in my um my
recent YouTube video
the the spell chess video
yeah it's such a like weird idea I don't
think this would ever happen in the game
um
spell chess is fun but when Eric will
win the US Open U.S Open of Chess or
tennis
probably have a better shot at chess
or if they ever make a US Open of duck
chess
I'll play a few more games I should move
faster this game
in time is of the essence
oh yeah Atomic chess Atomic just
everything explodes
that's very true
you don't understand the pieces yeah
it's it's a different piece set
I'm not sure if we can customize
pieces face Center
what did that do
I did nothing
refresh
oh oh we have the normal board for a
moment but
um
yeah I don't know
should probably not adjust the settings
during the game
turn off grassy okay I'll play around
with the settings between games
oh okay so now I use my jump jump over
the pawn and take the Rook
oh but opponent hits me back with it wow
I thought I'd trapped them but it's just
a fair trade
so I can't unfortunately I can't jump
over
I wonder can I
oh I have an idea here
I'm like I'm gonna freeze the queen
and then play King E2
and then after black snacks move my jump
is going to replenish
so it seems logical for black to respond
by freezing my queen
it's only piece that's attacking the
black queen
but when they freeze my queen
I'll use my jump to jump over my queen
to take it with a rook
also this Knight is still hanging too
but I'm more interested in winning the
queen
and even if my opponent's watching and
here's what's coming
I don't think they can stop it
oh fancy
wait I have to be careful I think this
is okay
because I don't have my freeze upon has
still five reasons
so any check could be deadly
but this track
wait what
oh that check was deadly Ah that's just
checkmate
I lost two in a row
wow
I thought I was being so five hen
my opponent was six head
Knight takes E4 oh no my queen I took
the bait
wow
let me explain
um
oops what happened the game
because black user freeze
and checked my king I have no way of
getting on a check and I can't counter
for use because I use my freeze to win
the fat Queen
oh it's so sad
I my jump doesn't help here
yeah these are the two things I would
normally be able to move
okay final game hopefully I can win a
game I've lost both teams so far
foreign
I feel like players are
are getting stronger in this
oh opponents chatting okay I'll respond
with a smiley face or actually let's
respond with the
the cool emoji
have to be extra cool
all right I really don't know any
opening strategy here
yeah the freeze does affect nine squares
so it's powerful when used correctly
as we just saw
yeah I want to do this
maybe this is a reasonable move
this and then this
so I want to win the night
oh settings theme
[Music]
standard
is there a save button
I click standard nothing changes though
maybe there's something else I have to
do but I only have time to to focus on
it right now
um yeah so we see the counter freeze
I play A5
I guess I'll play A5
my calculation is take and then I jump
and then white jumps and then
it's just all a fair trade
and in the end I'm hitting the knights
now white does not have
their jump replenished
wait so how does a replenishing work
because I'm calculating this and then
this
and then we'll be will I be threatening
to jump
one of those pieces
I could also freeze
probably not a great idea though so
let's develop
managing time better this game
Bishop C4 okay
safety
I do have to be careful because if I
move my knight then
the bishop could possibly jump
and there's a question about getting
more more spells as the game progresses
now we see the number next to the Spells
the total I have remaining
very tricky so they're threatening this
maybe I'll play H6 and freeze
the bishop
no
let's just play this
and this is unsettling
because I can't move my Knights unless I
take I could take and freeze
but no
let's play this
yeah even like simple
calculations are difficult because if
they take I take and freeze and they
counter freeze
okay so now I freeze this
and I want to win the bishop next
so they could counter freeze
but the encounter freeze I'll somehow
defend the pawn I think like Bishop B7
or E6
wait what did they do
oh wow that's almost checkmates
because they're threatening to jump and
take my king my only move
to not lose this
super fortunate there
okay
all right let's let's go on aggressive
all right so now I'm threatening to take
the king
and
I'm still trying to take the king
oh this jump but how do I make progress
and jump and take the knights
wait what if I just freeze
I have an idea but
let's take your first
okay I have a crazy crazy idea
Reeves
I I think this is winning
I'm scared It's Gonna backfire like last
time but
um I freeze this area
and I play this
now at first it seems bad because
the point can counter for you
but then I played this move
an opponent just resigns
so maybe for those that don't understand
this is basically checkmates
because when the king takes a queen only
needle looking move
I jump over the pawn and take the king
so that was a cool tactical combination
okay I gotta go thanks everyone for
watching maybe this will also go on
YouTube